hi and welcome to our webcast today on
MBA student insights women at the GSB my
name is Tony wallaby and I'm a first
year MBA student here at the GSB and
today I'm joined by Misha lily and Val
Young who are both second years and
about to graduate we'll be talking about
the student experience here on campus
and we're here to answer as many
questions as you might have to submit a
question just click on the chat button
at the top of your screen put in the
question and click send to all the
panelists so today we will be talking
about anything related to admissions
process or the application or financial
aid but people from the staff from the
MBA admissions office I here to answer
your questions you just type the
question into the chat box so let's
start with some introductions reishi and
fowl please just tell us a little bit
about yourselves where you're from what
you did before the GSB and what you're
looking to do after graduation so okay
I'm from Texas born and raised went to
University of Chicago for for undergrad
and then spent four years in Chicago
doing executive search where I helped
build a digital health practice and then
came here and after school I'll be doing
health tech thanks thank you thank you
hi I'm Val and I am from New Hampshire
originally went to Bowdoin College in
Brunswick Maine I graduated in 2008
shortly thereafter I moved to DC and I
spent about 6 years after college before
coming to business school in politics
most recently I was in the US Senate as
a chief of staff over the summer I
worked at the Boston Consulting Group in
San Francisco so I'll be going back
there after graduation I am interested
in hopefully starting something on my
own at some point but I'm spending a
little time and consulting before
figuring out exactly what my career path
will be Thank You moe so for me again
I'm Tallulah la vie I'm originally from
Nigeria
and I moved to the US about seven years
ago for college I went to Grinnell
College in Iowa I double majored in
computer science and math and after that
I worked as a program at go
and then I did it for two years and then
came to the GSB last September after
after the GSB I'm looking to remain in
technology but but do something more
like business development versus being a
program or software engineer and on the
tech side so let's get started with
questions from you guys so the first
question is what's it like for we may
not stop with both inside and outside
the classroom
sure
so I think I was pleasantly surprised
actually by the sort of climate and
atmosphere for women here our class at
least the class of 2016 I'm not sure
about the class for the next year was
about a 60/40 split male to female and
we had one of the highest percentages of
women at the GSB in history and so
that's been really nice I think that I
have found a really supportive group of
male and female friends here I
definitely have found there are some
challenges coming into a place that are
into an industry sort of as a whole that
has been historically male-dominated and
I think the GSB and the student body are
working through that and sort of making
progress as we go along and I'm happy to
obviously talk about that a bit more but
by and large I've actually found it much
more inclusive than I even anticipated
coming in so that's been really nice I
think the thing I'd add on to that is I
think starting our year we started we
have this woman in management board and
we started having formal members who
were men women join and we've had such a
huge movement of of guys being involved
in women and you just feel the support
for what used to be considered women's
issues is just issues that we all talk
about and we all think about so there's
definitely an open environment to talk
about what it means to be a working mom
or to or just like a working parents
rather than saying working mom and and
conversations like that which is which
is really great and refreshing I
actually was thinking of one other thing
that there's been some really great
formal stuff that Stanford has done I
think informally
one of the things that our classmates
have really pushed is diversifying some
of those kind of side conversations and
group meetings and things particularly
about entrepreneurship and the startup
world so I think we found in the first
quarter maybe first two quarters there
were a lot of male groups that were
having informal informal conversations
about entrepreneurship and for whatever
reason women weren't really as
integrated into that and I think women
were having their own separate
conversations and I know a few
classmates of ours made a very concerted
effort to start bridging those two
groups together start thinking about
forming startup teams together and just
kind of allowing that ecosystem to
crossover between male students and
female students and that has been
something that I've really appreciated
you know going forward because I think
those are the informal networks and
informal groups that start to really
make a big difference as you as you move
through your career so thank you very
good points so the next question is how
do you think about timing to get your
MBA in terms of stepping out of your
career for two years and possibly
starting a family or something
I think getting your babies a little bit
similar to having exactly getting your
MBA is a little similar to having a baby
which is there may be no perfect time um
I think when one time and it is a really
good time is if you want to pivot and
especially with regard to having a
family I know a lot of families actually
have a baby while they're at the GSB
maybe in the second year because that
seems like a good transition point so I
guess my advice would be figure out
first is that this is something that you
really want is this something that's
going to benefit your career and they
really think about how and why and then
just after that if you want it and if
you want a family to just decide how
you're going to start piecing those
things together it will never be perfect
the timing will never be great but you
can do it yeah I would say as somebody
that got married in my first month of
Business School I would echo Brittany's
mom said like the best laid plans you
know always go awry so I had worked
for about six years before I came I
think again Trish's point it felt like I
had had some really awesome and
interesting accomplishments and I was
ready for some new challenges I think
spending some time thinking about when
and why you want to go is really
important and I would sort of prioritize
that the family stuff I think is tough
for women at any point in this in our
careers at business school and you know
career trajectory thereafter and and
it's something that you know you and
your family and your partner have to
spend some time thinking about I think
that Business School it'll fit into your
life however you need it to fit into
your life if you're doing something like
I'm doing which is kind of going into a
consulting firm where you're gonna have
a couple of years where you may want to
not have kids at that point in time you
may want to think about applying a year
or two earlier than you might I mean I'm
30 I'm probably slightly on the older
side at the GSB our average older and it
is something that we thought about at
one point like what time will when will
we graduate when do we want to have a
family so I think you make it work but
it's something that you may want to at
some point kind of look to the future
and start backing out and saying what
are my goals because I think your family
goals are as important as your career
and your education goals and you should
just make sure that you're thinking
about those two things in tandem but I
will say I think the GSB is a place
where you can accommodate whatever you
choose and whatever needs to be
accommodated in your life so so don't
let it be a hindrance but I would I
would be thoughtful about it thank you
next question is are there unique
opportunities for women in the MBA
program who are interested in pursuing a
career in the nonprofit sector that's a
great question I don't have I did not
pursue a career in the nonprofit sector
I think you might have that so I when I
came from the government sector which is
different but related there is the
Social Innovation Career Services Center
and I think that they have done a really
great job at building out a pretty
robust both curriculum for
folks that are interested in nonprofit
management you know I've sort of social
innovation type fields and then they
have a special certificate that you can
sort of apply your credits towards and I
think some really great counselors and
advisers that have quite a distinguished
career in those fields so I would say
I've kind of like dipped in and out of
that a little bit I will be getting the
certificate but I haven't probably
utilized it to the degree that some of
our classmates that are very focused on
nonprofit sector have that said I think
through 390s which are our independent
studies through you know the CSI program
and a few others there's a lot of
opportunities to both within the
curriculum and outside the curriculum
design sort of study and internships and
externships that allow you to get
involved in the nonprofit sectors you
may have to be a little bit more
creative if they're not tak or they're
not San Francisco or Palo Alto
affiliated or located but I think that
there is there there's a lot of support
here and a number of resources to help
you be successful yeah thank you for
that just one thing I would like to add
is actually about the social innovation
trips all right yeah so we have social
innovation trips like just like every
other study trip but this these trips
are just concentrated and focused on
social innovation I guess yeah so we
have I know we have a bunch two
countries in Africa so we have
one-to-one Uganda maybe South Africa
next year and men women included they
all go on these trips but these trips
are a good example of how you actually
get to see the practical applications of
different products and different
innovative ideas on people's lives and
how it actually impacts people in Rwanda
Uganda okay so like that's a very very
unique opportunity that you can explore
if you and I interested I don't know if
there are any women's specific
opportunities I do know that to a Alina
want an award right for Social
Innovation in some in a scholarship more
for the GSB also Alina I think and
Ashley right are starting their own
nonprofit business and so there are
women killing it at the GM in Inman on
top
sector and and there is I don't want to
miss because I don't know enough about
the specifics but there is a good amount
of matching funds and fundraising
available for students that over the
summer want to do nonprofit work if
they're working at a 501 C 3 and also
obviously like really great loan
forgiveness programs for those that go
into nonprofit work after the GSB so
those are two things that I'm sure the
admissions and other staff members you
could talk about in more detail but
there's there's quite a bit of financial
assistance that's provided as well thank
you so next question is how many of the
teachers and faculties are women you
know percentage I don't know the
percentage I do know that some of our
most rock star faculty members are women
and we have maggie neal for negotiations
i'm actually doing an independent study
with her she's an incredible human being
fantastic researcher we have Deb yes
exactly who coupled who with Amy Cuddy
they did the work on power and poses and
those are two of my my favorite
professors do you have yeah I would say
um candidly I think they're not enough
women faculty at the GSB my intuition
tells me that that is probably true
across most of the business schools
certainly most of the top business
schools I think that GSB I know in their
Dean search and in other communications
that we've had with the administration
has really focused on being particularly
proactive about increasing the numbers
especially as we get up to the 10-year
level it's not I think where many of us
would like like it to be in a perfect
world but there are some really
fantastic women and I think they get a
lot of support and buyer who is my first
year accounting professor one the
distinguished Teaching Award from the
students one year which is the student
gave an award to the best teacher at the
GSB so yeah I don't have a number in
percentage
I think the percentage would be lower
than what most of us in this room would
like it to me I think that's a problem
sort of across the board in academia at
this level and in this in this sector
but but it's
thing that we talk about quite a bit the
administration talks about quite a bit
and you know it is trending in the right
direction
I do think women faculty are celebrated
yes sure I mean they're doing amazing
things some of them are like far
outshine their male colleagues and their
male peers but I think you know in in a
perfect world there'd be more of them
and I think there will be more of them
as as time goes on another faculty who's
doing well thank you for the very honest
answer next question what has been your
favorite experience any GSB - talk it's
uh it's not a there I mean there's been
a million of classroom things and a
number of professors that I am super
close with but my favorite thing about
the GSB is talk which we do it's the
whole whole school and community is
invited but mostly you do it with your
class and it's kind of like moth Radio
Hour if anyone has ever heard of that
it's basically 30 minutes or so where or
in an hour once a week at night where
everyone packs into the MBA lounge and -
people give about a 30-minute talk of
their life whatever they choose to focus
on it's in those moments when I'm at the
GSB that I'm like just reminded of what
a wonderful fantastic community we have
and I feel most grateful for being there
we're getting to know these amazing
classmates we're hearing stories that
are so different and so you know
impactful and I think that that's
something that will stick with me for
for decades so I want to add on to that
and then I'll share my favorite I think
another really special thing about talk
is how people are able to share things
that they wouldn't usually share and in
a different setting and in creating that
not only a safe space for that but also
celebrating and loving in that us
bringing us all closer it's a really
wonderful and I think unique thing that
we have here and I'm sure other places
have it as well but it's really special
for my favorites I just love getting to
know my classmates and that's
silly probably but as Val said they are
each person has something incredible to
share and just warm wonderful
personalities there are very few people
that I wouldn't want to spend time with
and so any of the activities around that
so we have small group dinners where
first year you can you are in a lottery
system and you get a randomly assigned
to you can host a small group dinner
with randomly assigned two people so you
get to know different people in the
class and that was one of my way to get
to know people whom I usually wouldn't
run into and I and I really loved that
experience and with my really good
friendships today came out of that we
thank you know you can say super sassy
[ __ ] challenge for charity we do so
hard right and you also like the CMC
committee I know but anyways c4c is a
sporting event that happens
hosted by Stanford where West Coast
business schools I invited to compete in
different sports and I was in charge of
that this year was amazing I played
basketball in college so I brought my
basketball skill yeah and I helped
stomping I did my battle well in college
but I also got my yeah it's the
culmination of a year-long fundraising
and volunteering competition among nine
West Coast business schools and then we
use the weekend to kind of like
celebrate and bring everyone together so
there's 1,300 students that come to the
GSB and it's it's fantastic
yeah really fun yeah and we end with a
dance with the dance competition and
it's just like yeah just amazing yeah
okay next question
has any particular club including but
not limited to the women in business
club how did tangible impact on your
career in terms of giving you new
opportunities that you might otherwise
found so the clubs are a great place to
get new opportunities any of them all of
them the way it works is a lot of jobs
are funneled through the Career
Management Center but the age Club
has specific connections with people in
their industry and so sometimes jobs go
directly to the club leaders I'm and
funnel that way so definitely if you
want to be in healthcare enjoying the
healthcare club if you want to be in DC
join the DC Club it's it's a great way
to do it and in general our network is
incredible and you should use it so in
that agent I'm just talking about your
classmates so even more so than the club
if there's a company that you really
want to work at forget if they have a
job open reaching out to a classmate who
either works there or know someone who
worked there and can give you an intro
actually really helps and turn
especially if you want to pivot and your
resume wouldn't scream I am the person
for this job it's a really way good way
to get a foot in there and to advocate
for yourself so I would strongly
recommend doing that not only at the GSD
but in life in general I'm figuring out
how you can use your network to get even
to new places yeah I think that's that's
true I would say like I'm a member of
the BC Club though I don't know
immediate plans to go into venture
capital and there's been just some
amazing lunches and dinners and
opportunities to meet in network with
people that I would not probably have
other otherwise that if I hadn't been in
the club or you know what climbed on to
dinners that some of my friends host um
in the immediate term that's not
something that I'm going to probably
capitalize on but long term these are
some really cool fun interesting
relationships and interactions with
people that I otherwise would would
never have been able to make the
connection with so thank you I think we
had lots of questions so we'll try to
know as many as possible so the next one
is do you have any plans to transition
into a new industry or new role after
your MBA and how do you think the GSB
has prepared you so far so I have very
strong opinions on this topic um yes and
yes for me I am currently still
interviewing both I said earlier I'm
gonna be working in how to either health
tech or tech I'm in the process of
interviewing right now and how has the
GSB prepared me for the transition first
I'm just gonna stop here and say if you
come to the GSB or anywhere and you know
that you
want to pivot do not take a breather on
that you need to figure out what you
want to do how what steps need will get
you there and start mapping that out
immediately and this is something we
talk a lot about MBA two years there's a
lot of do whatever you want during the
summer you know love of Allah and that
can be wonderful and you may still want
to do that and will not regret your
decision but you need to do it with full
knowledge you can if you want to make a
huge pivot using that summer to do it is
really key it's much easier to get a
summer internship and a new function and
new role or either/or or both and then
it is to just do it full-time later so
just think about that and the next thing
I'd say what prepares you to both your
classmates who can help you prepare for
the interviews which is extremely
helpful since they've done the jobs
before they probably interview people
for those roles before it's really
helpful to use to leverage that and then
on the other side some class is really
healthy if you're gonna go into a job
where you going to have to do financial
modeling and you've never done that
before take financial model modeling
you're gonna go into operations take
operations make friends with the
professor get to know more about the
subject it's really upon you though to
know what you want to get out of the
experience and to be really focused
about getting it yeah I would add so I
went into consulting which was totally
different than what I'd done before I
used both the consulting Club the Career
Management Center alumni like a ton of
GSB alumni that are in different firms
to both learn about sort of show my
interest in and then prepare for
interviews I think that in particular
our classmates that offer to do case
interviews with me was some of the most
meaningful and helpful that I got so I
think that is sort of facilitated in
part with Career Management Center in
part separately through the consulting
Club and just people of giving their
time so I think that that is true across
a number of industries and it's just my
experience with consulting I would also
say I've been working through startup
garage on a start-up with another
classmate of mine startup grudge is one
of it's a really great class if you're
interested in starting something
and that sort of design center of
thinking takes you through a couple
quarters of really going from zero to
sixty on a startup and that has been
really fantastic as far as just
introducing me to entrepreneurship
connecting me with investors and leaders
in the field and other students that are
doing something similar and so that as a
class I think has been like an
unbelievable crash course in
entrepreneurship which is something that
long-term I hope to get into and it's
definitely been like kind of giving me
like the training wheels almost to go
and do it on my own so thank you yeah um
the next question is are there any
specific initiatives whether classes
leadership coaching or any of that has
helped prepare women students in
particular for a career and
traditionally male-dominated industries
acting with power right I mean I yeah
that's a good I mean so I think whim
focuses on a quite a bit through
different programming and the
conversations that they facilitate I
think that there are some really cool
classes including the one we were
talking about with Jeff Greenfield which
is called acting with power which is all
about kind of understanding how you
present how you take power give away
power I think some of the things that we
think about when you think about women
not speaking up in meetings or how you
sit and I'm eating or how you approach a
difficult conversation I think I mean
there's women entrepreneurship yeah
that's been a great class actually yeah
which is also focused I I don't know
that there are a ton of initiatives
focused on women getting into male
dominant and dominated industries there
is there are male-dominated industries
and if you're a woman who wants to get
into that all the support in the world
to get you there including male
classmates who were in or will be in
those industries professors who I know
have helped some of our female
colleagues and classmates get into those
industries such as private equity search
mystery so I think women and
entrepreneurship is a great example the
specific class so there's a professor
fern
mendel bombs in investing angel
investing petrol capital few other
things she hosts a class specifically
around sort of encouraging women to get
into entrepreneurship either by starting
something or getting into the investing
side and brings in a ton of women in the
valley and also men in the valley that
are really supportive of getting more
women involved in those industries and
that is sort of soft skills like meeting
these people hearing from other people
that have a similar world for you to you
and being able to picture yourself in
that role and also some like really
tangible conversations that we had
amongst us about what's holding women
back from being in those industries what
would you look for you know how do we
start to change the culture so that's a
great example there's also a lot of
programming around women through the
through the CMC and others just about
like public speaking and you can get
like one-on-one coaching and things like
that so and and negotiation negotiations
yeah so there ya I mean I think there's
a lot of support yeah thank you
next question do you have any insights
on what the experience is like for
partners joining the girlfriends or
wives at Stanford especially given the
location of Stanford and delivering
experience on campus yeah I have made
fantastic GSB SSO significant other
husband who lives on campus with me so I
live in Escondido village I have this
awesome one bedroom which is so below
market rate in Palo Alto
it's incredible if I could squat there
for the next 10 years I would stay and I
think so my husband is it is definitely
different like having a male significant
other like a male a so then what it's
more traditional which is female s I was
probably my husband loves Palo Alto
which really helps he says it's like our
country club that he gets to come home
to he works in the city he has made a
great network of both other male Essos
and then some of my male classmates it
definitely took a little bit of time for
him to in you know get himself into the
community he takes the Cal train into
San Francisco
it's not a perfect commute but tons of
people do it
he had like a really good support
network I think the best thing for him
which has been so great is he has been
able to talk
into the GSP Network for his own career
career ideas and transition so he
recently moved from energy clean tech to
health tech and really utilized the GSP
network for that both the Esso community
and the student community and I think
that you know what has been the nicest
thing about this is you know my GSP
network has become his GSP Network and
we get kind of dumped on the network
which is really nice
so I'm going to give a slightly
different take I also have significant
other he's long distance and lives in
Chicago and my fiance and so I will say
it's hard yeah oh yeah it's definitely
hard like you go from maybe living
together spending over a lot of your
time together even if you're working
really hard to being a thrown into a
completely different environment where a
lot of your time is spent meeting new
people doing your GSB things and it's
really it can be really hard to
integrate your suppose both both of you
to live in in that world and I just want
to acknowledge it's hard because I think
it would be hard at any business well
I'm actually pretty sure it is just
given the experience but just be aware
of that and kind of talk about talk
about it and talk about how you're going
to work with that its own it's just a
difference in lifestyle a difference in
the time you can allocate your
relationship it also I will say
something in some ways it's been easier
because he's long distance so he doesn't
have to hang out with cheese fears all
the time he has his home group of
friends in some ways it's harder because
at this point Val's husband has friends
inside and outside of the class who me
whom he also loves who've become part of
his family and that happens around
second year so I shall never quite got
there right but he never had like the
rough roughness of hmm me not being at
home all the time because we were apart
so yeah I mean it's definitely a
challenge you have to spend a lot of
time thinking about how you allocate
your time I think the one thing you'll
realize that Business School is that
time is the rest of the precious
resource and so when you have a
relationship you need to figure out how
you how you fit that in with all the
other stuff that you have going on but
but lot of people are doing it there's
lots of people talking about it so we
also ride it
yeah yeah so unfortunately we're almost
out of time and we still have many
questions but just to summarize this
like reishi and BA what would be your
final pieces of advice before you
graduate what advice do you have for
people watching today and I guess for me
to do something to be a second here next
year I think the one thing that I've
gotten out of the GSB and I would say it
starts with the application is this idea
of authenticity um which I friend Mike
Dean talks about but the GSB focuses a
lot on being introspective and being
really true to who you are and aligning
you're both professional and personal
values and desires to that and that's
and it starts with the application like
what matters most to you well really
think about that question mm-hmm I did a
lot of it introspective research when I
did my essay and that really helped me
figure out what I really wanted out of
the GSB out of life out of my personal
life and helping me pay the path forward
and I would I would say do the same for
you to do the same because that journey
will just continue when you're here yeah
I think I would echo a lot of what
Ritchie said and and in addition what
what made me choose the GSB was the
community I think this is the best place
in the world it's the most fantastic
group of people and supportive group of
people in your application and when you
get here remember that you are an
important person part of that community
because of the unique things that you
bring I think I spent the first you know
quarter or half year even worrying that
I wasn't like business school enough or
that my background in government wasn't
valuable enough and as I leaving and
reflecting I'm realizing that I had so
much to offer I have so much to offer
and then my classmates have a lot to
learn from me and I have a lot to learn
from them and so I would say come in
with the confidence that and apply with
the confidence that you will bring so
much to the community yourself and also
remember that you have so much to learn
from the people that are here and I
think that when you can embrace that
give and take you'll be in a place to
really capitalize on all of the GSB has
to offer
yeah the echo everything machine pal
said I'll just add something that I
heard from someone which blew my mind so
I'm flying to the GSB most people see it
as a marketing exercise so marketing
themselves and trying to showcase all
the great things you guys have done
which I'm sure are great things but
people see it more as marketing but
rather you should see it as accounting
what you're trying to take stock of
yourself
sothank you're trying to take stock of
your strengths and the areas you want to
improve on so yeah you're trying to
display this those strengths but you
also want to be aware of what you want
to get out of the experience like those
those parts of your life that you want
to change or you want to improve so even
though you want to get into the GSB like
you wanna you want to make sure it's a
good it's a good match both for you and
for the GSB and just like mission bow
said you wanna you wanna come through
authentic in your in your essay and in
your application just be yourself let
your personality shine and just we want
to get to icon in yeah Johnny no
marketing yeah so thank you um thank you
both for joining us today sharing on
this wisdom thank you for joining us
yeah thank you very much for joining us
you can learn more about the MBA program
on the GSB websites and the application
for the class after for the class
started in the fall of 2017 will be
available in June and if you have any
questions about the MBA program you can
submit them in the chat box as you've
been submitting them and the people to
start from the MBA admissions office
available to answer your questions
within the next 15 minutes thank you
very much again and have a wonderful day